around 3,000 refugees and migrants are
landing on Europe's shores every day
that's over 200-thousand people since
the beginning of July which is more than
the number that arrived in all of 2014
half of those making the journey are
Syrians followed next by Afghans and air
trains their countries have been riddled
by conflict and human rights abuses for
years but why are they rushing to Europe
now well Jordan Turkey and Lebanon have
taken in more than their fair share of
refugees there's not enough food space
or opportunity for them there so
Europe's larger economies offer more
promise that's why thousands of people
are making the dangerous journey across
the Mediterranean or through the Balkans
to get to Germany but refugees can only
apply for asylum in the first European
Union country they physically landed
recently Germany announced it would
break EU asylum law by taking in
hundreds of thousands of refugees no
matter which European country they
arrived in first there's also been a
rush to get through Hungary before it
completed a hundred and nine mile wall
across this border with Serbia Greece
Serbia and Macedonia have also been
helping refugees move further north in a
bid to get them out of their countries
faster it's all in a race against time
before winter arrives and the journey by
sea and land gets even more treacherous